hi I'm Evan Carmichael I'm excited today
because I've been asked to speak at the
strategic sales and marketing Expo
that's happening on April 25th in York
Region which is just north of the city
here in toronto and i'm excited because
all the proceeds from this event go to
support the Alzheimer's Society of york
region and my grandfather passed away
not too long ago from Alzheimer's so
it's a cause that's very near and dear
to my heart what I'm going to be talking
about is 14 ways to turn your business
into a marketing machine and I know a
lot of entrepreneurs struggle with
promoting themselves you may have a
great product or service you may be
really good at what you do but you have
a hard time getting the word out getting
customers in getting partnerships
created and so I'm going to talk about
14 different ways you can turn your
business into that almost automated
marketing machine to have customers
coming to you some of my friends are
gonna be on the panel as well there's
gonna be Donna Messer who is Canada's
networking Queen if you want to learn
anything about networking and how to get
in front of the right people you've
gotta listen to Donna and Gary shouldice
is another friend of mine who's going to
be talking about online marketing and
how it's more than just SEO which is
what a lot of people just think about
how to basically get your word out about
your business online it seemed a great
event it's an all day event I think it's
8 a.m. in the morning to four o'clock in
the afternoon I'm going to be speaking
later on in the day but I hope your go
in and sign up and join there's going to
be some free bonuses that are given out
and some auction items including the
ability to meet with me one-on-one talk
about your business hopefully get some
good advice to help you grow for more
information there's a website let me
pull that up here it is strategic sales
and marketing dot CA and again it's
April 25th hold the event I hope you go
check it out strategic sales and
marketing dot CA and I'll see you there
you